campers aren't working that's getting
super frustrating this is what it's like
on life below zero
cameras already down tough conditions
all around a fill-in
no heat no car no anything won't even
turn on too many times
we have battens it's just a typical day
in the Arctic
they confessed what we got takes a lot
of food to feed a bunch of people for a
few weeks out in the wilderness to make
the show while we're out there we're
getting ready for a winter move off and
the place we want to go is to the key
Wallach we go down there sometimes for
several months at a time and we hunt
fish and gathered it's worth the
challenge it's worth the dangers it's
worth the time and the unknown it
doesn't bother me because nobody knows
today we're loading up our entire show
in order to follow the hailstones to
keep wallet for some adventures out
there and part of what we have to do is
load everything that we need for a
couple weeks in the field one sled with
most of the camera gear personal camping
gear here their sled that mostly food a
bunch of propane a generator we use a
tremendous number of camera batteries on
a daily basis so we have to run a
generator when we're out in remote areas
I always carry this safety bag that's
got our communication devices lets us
keep in touch with our office in
Anchorage in LA and then also it's got
emergency provisions medical kit and
emergency shelter warm clothes and food
and fire and everything you would need
if you were stuck somewhere pretty
excited to go at hailstones are almost
ready to leave so we're going to start
up the machines and follow them out to
Kowalik
[Music]
[Music]
so we're carrying this big load out to
Kowalik we're going over these really
hard packed wind drifts and it's pushed
up the gate it's bent the gate the wrong
direction on two of these hitches now so
we're kind of in a bit of a sticky place
here
[Music]
so we're here in Kowalik we finally made
it a bit of a victory celebration going
on at 3 a.m. 110 miles over some really
rough terrain across tundra and frozen
Bering Sea and got here pretty much just
had to make hard luck shelter and get
some food into the crew we've got
everything that we need for the next
month with us in these four sleds roll
out our sleeping bags and get some rest
and then wake up the morning and build
our little tent city here everyone's
pretty excited to be here this is what
it takes to fall the hailstones in the
middle of nowhere
[Music]